this is you one of the many new players
ready to explore drive and get social in
the seamless massive and connected world
of the crew you're about to take on a
day in the one true MMO action driving
experience where the only limits are the
Atlantic and the Pacific
you begin with a low level ride you want
to work towards upgraded parts for a
faster stronger car and with many
missions to accomplish to get them for
now you're content to speed through the
gorgeous red woods of northern
california and take in the sheer beauty
of some of the crews vast and detailed
landscapes
however you're not alone there are
countless other drivers racing and
exploring at any given time
sometimes it takes getting left in the
dust to motivate you to start leveling
up in the crew there are plenty of fresh
faces and some familiar ones too
after just one race you and your friends
decide to crew up
now you can explore together share the
best sites in the land
and run missions and challenges as
through the more you ride with your crew
the stronger your ability to overcome
the toughest challenges your new crew
will be perfect for helping you finally
finish a takedown challenge you've been
struggling with
on the third attempt your crew crushes
now it's time to take down a rival crew
or two in the crew vs. proof PvP an
eight person race to see who has
bragging rights
another crew member wants to try a
getaway mission and you all fast travel
to take on the cops
time to bid your crew farewell and
explore the east coast on your own do
you discover that some of your friends
have already explored recording top
scores on the skill challenge
leaderboards you race and beat your
friends ghost cars and set a new record
at long last off to the garage reward
yourself for a hard day's work now that
you're feeling more confident with your
upgraded rod time for one last race to
end the day
it looks like all your endeavors have
paid off a photo finish for another day
in the world of the crew